coluche ans pas vous selon la suite ils
barrent le bol dans le métier que vous
bleu la pho bo papé et je sais j'ai
l'air un peu con non mais l'uniforme y
est pour beaucoup un à ses fans afin de
me dit toujours tu as signé sans
réfléchir et me dit j'ai demandé aux
autres ils ont fait pareil gestionnaires
on peut le prendre pour des cons on
argumente pascal d'annapolis ayed
examens et tout cantons du sud soit moi
je suis pro d2 ainsi jazz qui me disent
combien je dois alors il ya des examens
j'ai dû je sais pas 15 mois diront signé
là qu'avant j'ai appelé art ou faux j'ai
tout bon l'arnaqué c'est utile comme
métier tu le chef aidé tout le temps
l'agent de police et à l'automobile ce
que travaux est à l'inseec
l'uniforme se sent trahie et les
gonzesses sa chute quand on débute ou
1,91 cambodge ou impressionner par les
ont pas su les gens nous aiment pas ça
va être pas si nous ne la pour les
protéger est là pour les défendre
eh ben j'ai remarqué les gens plus ya
deux flics ou tondeuse plus au coeur des
français dans les mamies passionnant
dans les manifs on est obligé de taper
on peut pas pour le plaisir
un nom qui ont fait grâce à ses
magnifiques et épices dégradée dans les
cheveux longs la reconnaît pas et puis
dans les manifs et il ya les appariteurs
les appariteurs ces flics en civil comme
un humaniste par ceux qui cassent les
vitrines des 47 a perdu 13 ouvriers des
étudiants
déconnez pas se repiquer
et en plus grave ce jeudi lotois pas le
goût monte à pointer à l'impliquer
une phase hier et launay taper sur un
flic et dont 10 était une bavure
ouais ça va passer l'envi de balai à
jablah fumeurs impeccable on n'en passe
ya les gens qui disent oui à la police
un refuge pour les alcooliques qu'on a
pas voulu et fo ptt
nous en fait cette exagération moi je
vois je suppose un gros commissariat
mais je vois déjà elle use de musique je
suis fière power que jusqu'au 2 buts il
y en a au moins 15 qui boivent pas mais
jeudi en masse et comme dans tous les
propos un peu hard et brebis galeuses
sisoulith on a rouvert sa grande et n'a
repris qu'un troupeau à lui tout seul et
bien c'est quand même un métier où
comment wade rôle
l'autre jour et indique nice il vient
pour chercher une carte d'identité pas
et tu me donneras grèce de son coiffeur
on faisait pour taper avec le plat de la
main dans le dos comme ça ici ça fait
mal ne savent pas déconner avec ça non
non et à rigoler pas là mais je m'en
fous je répondais non pas déconner quand
même j'aimerais que les gens des traces
après le pont de porter plainte un
manager pour porter plainte vu pendant
qu'ils viennent au commissariat mais
dans l'ensemble ils viennent pas on n'a
pas à se plaindre on sur la gueule alors
a pris l'avantagé avec les mauves est à
la grille parce qu'on fait des jeux et
bien robert été chercher sa tondeuse
rambert mais c'est à lui inscrit pas
fourni à rennais qui est la chose du
tout y mouille a beaucoup péché sur une
finale à couper le schmilblick minutes
de bon il a le nail art is more est
décollée faugoo de 31,6 mans par un
blanc et au bout de trente blâmons pas
en un conseil de discipline ou peut être
dégradée et comment
tiens un exemple l'autre jour j'étais
deux factions une intersection affectés
à la surveillance des usagers bon en
clair je buvais carrefour j'étais là
depuis un bon quart d'heure je foutais
rien savait qu'on fout rien même quand
enfin vous rendez pas compte de ce que
vous faites des vrais boulots mais nous
quand on fait rien j'étais là je foutais
rien et j'aurais aimé qu'ils s'amenaient
thiam qui papier je portais lequel elle
demande à une main en ridicule aux deux
points que tu veuilles pour ba genre de
mecs louches au foutoir basané ah oui
parce que nous nous apprend à
reconnaître les mecs louches a fait des
stages avec fraîcheur et tout peu saoulé
celui-là était pas franchement louche
mais très franchement basané alors moi
je l'avais vu le mec mais je faisais
mine que rien tiens je vais vous le
faire je sais bien
non mais je m'entraîne voilà le type il
était là il tourne et puis je sentais
qu'il n'osait pas le genre devait pas si
müller
alors finalement à temps a finalement le
mec qui s'amène pas de monsieur l'agent
excusez moi à ce qui est surtout pour
m'indiquer pense qu'il est excusez moi
le commissariat de police parce que je
parle de mes papiers d'identité excusez
moi je dois par une déclaration
s'cusez moi oui vous avez vous pas t il